[Musique]
je dois pratiquer une intervention
chirurgicale urgente à baltimore je
prends n'importe quel vol qui me fera
arriver demain matin vous avez une
solution
monsieur je pense que nous avons le même
problème je viens d'avoir une idée c'est
quoi votre jauge ans je me marie demain
au mes félicitations medical journal
explique toute la question
[Musique]
quelqu'un
alex regardez moi vous êtes blessé à la
jambe
votre téléphone est fichue le mien n'a
pas de signal et on est très haut dans
la montagne
si on reste on est en sécurité mais si
on part les sauveteurs auront moins de
chance de me trouver je veux pas mourir
ici parce que vous vous avez trop peur
de tenter quelque chose
il ya des gens qui nous cherchent le
pilote n'avait pas rempli le plan de vol
personne ne sait où en est on a que nous
pour s'en sortir vous et moi
on peut tenir trois semaines sans manger
trois jours sans boire et trois heures
sans abri
on va peut-être mourir en cinq ans
et on se connaît même pas
on va pas mourir
aujourd'hui
alex allaitent